in this video you're gonna learn how to
use the law of sines to solve triangles
and we're going to determine whether
there's a one triangle to triangle or no
triangles possible by going through some
of these different cases here in the
angle-angle-side case the
angle-side-angle case the
side-side-angle
ambiguous case where you could
potentially have no triangle one
triangle or even two triangles we're
gonna go through eight examples go ahead
and feel free to skip ahead if you want
to see some of the other ones but let's
start with this first one notice they're
giving us angle angle side and you want
to figure that out as you're going
around the triangle clockwise or counter
clockwise right so angle angle side when
you have that situation there's only
going to be one triangle possible so
let's go ahead and solve for that one
triangle we've got 135 degrees if we
subtract from 180 that means that this
angle here must be 45 degrees and now
we're gonna do the law of sines now
remember the law science you want to
find you're basically to make a pair you
say the sine of 25 degrees over its side
opposite six equals sine of a hundred
and ten degrees over its side opposite
that's going to be side D and we're
gonna go ahead and cross multiply and
solve so we get B times the sine of 25
degrees equals six times sine of 110 if
we divide both sides by sine of 25
degrees that's going to give us B by
itself right so let's go ahead and do
that on the calculator make sure you're
in degree mode since these angles are in
degrees so six times sine of 110 all
divided by sine of 25 okay so we're
getting B is equal to thirteen point
three and I'm just gonna round to the
nearest tenth okay and now we just have
to solve for this side here across from
angle C see how that makes like a pair
so let's see for side see we've got sine
of 45 degrees it's over C is equal to
sine of 25 degrees over six so you just
want to make a proportion cross multiply
again we've got six times the sine of 45
degrees equals C times the sine of 25
degrees and it's just a viable sides by
sine of 25 to get C by itself
and let's see what that comes out to
check my work on this one six sine of 45
divided by sine of 25 okay I'm getting
about ten point zero and you solve that
triangle so just one triangle possible
when you have angle-angle-side now this
one we're getting into angle-side-angle
see how that side is like in between the
two angles is called the included side
when you have angle side angle you also
only have one triangle possible so here
what we've got is ten 105 degrees so
that's 115 subtract from 180 that gives
us this missing angle 65 degrees and
then notice we've got a pair here and
let's go ahead and solve for angle side
bead across from angle B so we have sine
of 65 degrees over 15 and we have sine
of 105 over B okay now let's go ahead
and cross multiply we've got B sine of
65 equals 15 times sine of 105 and if we
divide both sides by sine of 65 we can
get side B by itself so let's see what
that comes out to 15 sine of 105 divided
by sine of 65 okay here we've got about
16 point 0 if you round so that's going
to be right here 16 point zero and we're
just left off solving for side a now
across from angle a so you know when you
do this law of sine just to tell you you
can do the reciprocal as well you could
say side a over sine of 10 degrees
equals let's just do 15 over sine of 65
now he's probably saying Mario why are
you doing it like that
well remember as long as you take the
reciprocal of both sides of the equation
it's still equivalent but the reason I'm
doing it is just to make it a little bit
easier a little bit less writing if I
multiply both sides by sine of 110 see
how I you know cross that ought to get a
by itself and you do the same thing to
the other side to keep it balanced so we
have 15 sine of 10 degrees divided by
sine of 65
and that's coming out 22.9 so that would
be this side right here beside a which
is equal to 2.9 it's getting more
interesting now here number three we're
getting into the side side angle which
we refer to as the ambiguous case
because it's not clear whether there's
one triangle possible two triangles or
no triangle and so what we want to do is
we want to drop an altitude like so see
that height right there so now if I
cover up the side of the triangle we
have a right triangle and you can see
sine of 40 degrees equals opposite over
hypotenuse right so let's write that
down here sine of 40 equals H over 18
and so now if I multiply both sides by
18 let's see what that height comes out
to we've got 18 sine of 40 which is 11.6
okay now this is where we assess is
there one triangle two triangles are no
triangles possible see I didn't really
draw this triangle to the proper scale
okay so I kind of tricked you little bit
on this one see how this is 11 see 11 if
I really drew this correctly 11 is like
like that okay and if we rotate it you
see how 11 it's not gonna reach this
other side here because the altitude is
11.6 11 is only gonna reach to about
there so really for this one there's no
triangle possible and you're not gonna
be able to solve it so it's not can't be
can't be drawn it wasn't drawn correctly
so we'll just write no triangle possible
no triangle okay
so for number four what do you think
about this one we've got again side side
angle ambiguous case side side angle
condition and what I'm going to do here
again is drop that altitude and we're
gonna analyze it so how do we find that
height well again if I cover up the side
of the triangle have a right triangle
sine of 20 equals H over 15 so sine of
20 degrees equals H over 15 multiply
both sides by 15 and let's see what that
comes out to 15 sine 20 I'm getting
about 5.1 okay now you see how this side
right here
it's not it's not shorter than five
point one like in this case where there
was no triangle possible however this
side here 20 is not in between five
point one and fifteen meaning that you
see the side here if I was to rotate it
it would actually extend past the side
here right so we can't turn this and
draw it like like two triangles
it can only swing out to the right like
this so there's only one triangle
possible here so then the question is is
well how do we solve the triangle when
we go back to our law signs okay and we
see the sine of angle over the side
opposites sine of 20 degrees over 20
okay that's a coincidence okay equals
sine of C over 15 multiply both sides by
15 and take the sine inverse of both
sides to get angle C by itself so let's
see what that comes out to 15 sine 20/20
and then remember we have to take the
sine inverse whenever you're solving for
the missing angle and I'm getting about
fourteen point nine okay degrees now if
we add these up okay and subtract from
180 we're getting about a hundred and
forty five point one for this angle I'll
just write that up here one hundred
forty five point one degrees and now we
just have to solve for the side across
from angle B using the law of sines
again so we have sine of one hundred
forty five point one all over V equals
sine of twenty over side twenty okay so
let's cross multiply 20 sine one forty
five point one equals V times the sine
of twenty divided both sides by sine of
twenty to get B by itself and we'll have
solve this triangle so twenty sine of
one forty five point 1 divided by sine
of twenty okay I'm getting about thirty
three point five and that's it you found
all the sides all the angles now for
number five this one's interesting
because again we have side side angle
that ambiguous case we want to drop that
altitude and analyze whether there's one
triangle to triangle or no triangle
possible so we've got sine of thirty
equals H over ten
so let's write that down here so sine of
30 equals H over 10 multiply both sides
by 10 I know sine of 30 is 1/2 1/2 times
10 is 5 and so you say Oh in a second
this height is 5 this side here is 5
what that means is I really didn't draw
it in the correct way if I really drew
this correctly this would you know this
5 here would be like this so it's
actually you know the altitude is right
here 5 so I I didn't you know it's not
that I you know a lot of times in the
book they'll give you the triangle like
that because they don't want to give it
away they want you to realize you know
what kind of a triangle it is it's a
right triangle and it's actually a
special right triangle we have 30 60 90
and we know then that this side is X 2 X
and X 2 root 3 so this side is going to
be 5 root 3 and you solved a number 6
we've got an obtuse triangle number 7 we
also have an obtuse triangle this is
interesting and it's also interesting
because it's the side side angle side
side angle condition so how many
triangles do we have well when it's
obtuse you're either gonna have one
triangle or no triangle so how do we
know if it's none or 1 well in a
triangle okay you always want to have
the longest side across from the largest
angle and of course with its own choose
triangle the longest side has to be
across from that obtuse angle because
that's gonna be the largest angle in the
triangle but look what we have here see
5 and 6 so again I tricked you a little
bit on this problem the way I drew the
triangle if I really drew it more to
scale 5 is really gonna be something
like like that okay maybe you know it
doesn't quite reach because if this is 6
you know it's not going to extend it to
this point here now say you didn't
notice that and you said Marriott you
know I just did those law of sines I did
sine of 1 10 over 5 sine of angle B over
6 I solved it but I got an error on my
calculator so that's another way you can
realize all something's off here but so
no triangle possible on number 6 for
number 7 this one is good you can see
we've got the largest angle and the side
across from the largest angle is the
longest side so there's only gonna be
one triangle possible so we can go and
dive into our love
a sign sign of 130 over the side
opposite equals sine of angle B over its
side opposite right multiply both sides
by five and take the sine inverse to get
angle B by itself so let's see what we
get on this one check my work 5 sine of
135 Ida by 8 and then we're going to
take the sine inverse of that answer and
we're getting twenty eight point six
degrees and if we add these up and
subtract from 180 you can find angle a
so twenty eight point six plus 130 take
that away from 180 we get twenty-one
point four degrees now all we have to do
is solve for side a across from angle a
and let's see what we get for that we
get sine of twenty one point four over
side a equals sine of we'll just go one
thirty over a tie like to go back to the
original numbers if at all possible
if we cross multiply eight sine of
twenty one point four okay equals a
times sine of 132 by both sides by sine
of 130 to get a by itself and let's see
what we get for that one eat a sine of
twenty one point four divided by sine of
130
okay I'm getting three point eight and
we solved the try ok last example I
saved the best one for last this is a
really interesting problem see if you
can do it on your own and if you made it
this far in the video put a comment in
the comments below to let me know that
you've stuck around till the end I know
a lot of people bail after her first
first couple problems but for this one
what do you think the first thing we
have to do is we have to drop an
altitude okay to figure out if there's
one triangle two triangles or no
triangle possible now again you can see
we've got a right triangle sine of 40
equals H over 12 so let's go ahead and
figure out what that is multiply both
sides by 12 and that's 12 times a sine
of 40
okay so that comes out to 7.7 okay very
interesting why is this interesting
because see the side across from the
secured angle eight that's in between
7.7 and 12 which means that we can take
the side and rotate it okay and I didn't
draw my triangle super great but just so
you can see we could have drawn it like
this okay
meaning that each side was here and
we've got at this isosceles triangle
we've got this you know obtuse triangle
here with this angle here being obtuse
so what we can do is we're gonna split
up into two triangle so see if I can
draw this here for us we've got this
triangle right here okay this is angle a
V and see this is 40 degrees that's all
we have and then we've got the original
triangle which I'll put right here this
is still 40 degrees this is a this is B
this is C C it could have been really
drawn in either of these ways if they're
just giving us this limited amount of
information side side angle right okay
so now what we need to do is we need to
solve for angle C Y angle C because
we've got a pair sine of 40 over 8
equals sine of C over 12 let's write
that down
equals sine of C over 12 let's multiply
both sides by 12 and it'll take the sine
inverse of both sides so 12 sine 40
divided by 8 and take the sine inverse
okay I'm getting seventy four point six
so which triangle is at four well you
can see it must be for this one right
here seventy four point six but notice
what's interesting here see how this
forms an isosceles triangle because this
is eight and this is eight and we know
the base angles of an isosceles triangle
are congruent so these are both 74.6 but
you see this angle here next to the 40
is four here but right next to 74.6
these form a linear pair which means
that 180 minus 74 point six is 105 point
four seven that's this angle right here
which is this angle right here in this
triangle right so now if we add these up
and subtract four 180 105 point what is
105 point four
so that's 40 plus 100 5.4 take that away
from 180 we're getting thirty four point
six and over here we have forty plus
seventy four point six and take that
away from 180
we've got sixty five point four degrees
okay now all we have to do is solve for
side B that's across from angle B okay
we'll have to do it separately for each
of these two triangles right so let's go
ahead and do that we've got sine of 40
over its side opposite which is eight
equals sine of thirty four point six
over D okay so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna cross multiply and solve so
let's do that we've got eight sine
thirty four point six equals B times the
sine of 40 divide both sides by sine of
40 so that we can get B by itself right
okay so eight sine of 36 divided by sine
of 40 gives us seven point three okay so
we've got seven point three we solve
that triangle this one over here same
thing we've got sine of 60 5.4 over side
B equals sine of 40 degrees over eight
so let's cross multiply and solve so
we've got eight times the sine of sixty
five point four divided by the sine of
40 okay and so we've got eleven point
four if we round now if you want to see
more examples about the ambiguous case
and solving whether you've got one
triangle to triangle or no trying on how
to tell I'll put a link to that video
right there where we go into some more
examples I'll see over in that video
you